当我和我的对象对某一件事情发生争执，
有矛盾的时候，
我就会抽离出来，
我想一下这件事情我们两个人意见不一致，
认知不统一，
这件事情会影响到我的身体健康吗？
会影响到孩子的健康成长吗？
会影响到我的工作赚钱吗？
会让我产生财产损失吗？
如果这次几个答案都是否定的，
那我就由他去，
我就说老公听你的，
你做主就行了，
我就主要是想解决一下我个人的性格，
还有处理问题的方式，
以及夫妻关系好。
你说啊，
我个人私下总结，
我感觉我可能有一点点呃趣味类型，
反驳欲会比较强，
比如我可能让我老公去收拾卫生间的地面，
那可能就会说，
你看就是60%都是你的头发，
我可能下意识的就会去说，
你要这么说的话，
那你的房间是不是我也被我打扫了？
第2个我可能会有逃避型人格，
比如说我一些小事儿调侃的问题啊，
我可能惹到他了，
呃，
我感觉他会有点不开心，
我会去用岔开话题想转移注意力的方式去解决这件事情，
起出小事化了，
但是他可能比较在意，
说我现在可能不开心了，
你要正面去迎接这个问题，
不要不承认。
第3个就是我感觉我有点自由散漫。
啊，
我可能我生气了，
他就是说我们今天要吃什么呀，
我带你去吃什么，
或者他可能给我日常的开个玩笑呀，
说一些什么其他话，
我就不会说是再再去追究这件事情，
可能就会放下了，
也不会去生气了。
现在最大的问题就是我俩掰扯事情的时候，
我会一直想要跟他讲我当时是怎么想的，
我想解释这件事情，
我的视角认为你生气了，
我需要解释清楚，
他的视角是你不需要解释，
错了就是错了，
你要么认错，
要么把这件事情哄好了，
把我哄开心了，
所以他现在认定我比较犟，
你一定要掰扯，
只要我陷入了，
想证明自己没有他说的那些情况的时候，
就会让他比较暴跳如雷，
比较凶，
有时候我们可能会当着孩子的面就是吵架，
我的一个问题就是我应该怎么改变这种争吵，
让我们俩争吵变少一些，
我我捋一捋啊，
你有孩子了，
你的目的不是说我要不要换个人，
你的的是说我要跟这个人好好过，
我怎么能跟这个人过得好一点，
少吵一点架，
是这样的，
对不对，
对的，
我有一个心法，
这个心法在我的婚姻生活当中的话，
为我的幸福指数添砖加瓦，
是非常重要的一个心法，
这个心法是什么呢？
凡是。
就是一回合原则，
一回合原则是什么意思？
比如说，
哎，
我觉得他穿这个衣服好看，
我建议他今天穿这个，
他要是答应好，
这个回合就结束了，
他要是不答应，
这个回合也结束了，
以后对孩子也是说，
今天想让孩子穿这个鞋，
他要是喜欢，
他穿就结束了，
他是不喜欢，
他不穿，
我不会第二次再去说你一定要穿这个东西。
这是我的一回合原则，
当我和我的对象对某一件事情发生争执，
有矛盾的时候，
我就会抽离出来。
我想一下，
这件事情我们两个人意见不一致，
认知不统一，
这件事情会影响到我的身体健康吗？
会影响到孩子的健康成长吗？
会影响到我的工作赚钱吗？
会让我产生财产损失吗？
如果这几个答案都是否定的，
那我就由他去，
我就说老公听你的，
你做主就行了，
老公你说的对，
我现在真是这样，
呃，
跟我的对象的话，
我俩不吵架，
我俩也没有什么发脾气的时候，
因为我遵从了这回和原则，
遵从了这4个问题，
只要这个我和他之间发生了矛盾和分歧，
我就拿这4个问题在心里来问我自己，
我发现生活当中基本上没有什么事情啊，
可以上升到这4个维度，
被生活中的事情我都随他去，
你想怎么办就怎么办，
你想今天叫物业师傅来可以，
你想明天叫他来可以，
你想叫他来修个屋。
点可以，
你想叫他来换个灯可以，
你不想叫他来也可以，
都行。
我也是因为之前关注了你很久，
其实我会考虑你说的权衡利弊，
因为我很清楚知道他的优点是什么，
我们俩相处起来，
他的好的地方，
这个家庭好的地方在哪，
所以我会想要去把我们的婚姻经营好好。
希望你能够把这四个问题每天啊，
一旦发生了分歧，
一旦你想怼他，
一旦你想吵架，
一旦你想回嘴，
一旦你想反驳，
你就拿四个问题问自己，
第一，
这件事情会影响我的身体健康吗？
第二，
这件事情会影响到孩子健康成长吗？
第三，
这个事情会影响到我的工作赚钱吗？
第4，
这件事情会让我有很大的财产损失吗？
好，
这四个问题答案都是否定的，
既不会影响我的身体健康，
也不影响孩子的健康成长，
也不响我工作赚钱，
也不会让我造成太大的经济损失，
我都听你的，
老公你说了算。
我比较客观的说一下，
他的认知其实是在我之上的，
我们在不吵架的时候，
我其实是很明白，
他会带着我往前走，
我的认知也是一直在进步的，
吵架的时候我会比较上头，
我就理不清楚了。
不要试图在两个人都针锋相对的时候去争一个谁的认知高谁的。
观点对，
因为这个世界本就没有对错，
这个世界每一个人所看到的世界，
感知到的世界，
其实并不是同一个世界。
第二个问题，
其实我们日常感情是比较好的，
不吵架的时候，
嗯，
他是比较粘人的，
他会经常想要主动亲亲我呀，
上班的时候，
他路上可能我们俩会打电话，
比如说他路程40分钟，
我们可能就打半小时，
比如说一小时，
他可能就会打四五十分钟，
这种我们会一起跟朋友聚会，
一起运动做饭。
但是一个很隐蔽的问题，
当我们很久没有亲密关系了，
之前讨论过没有亲密接触这件事情的时候，
他说不吵架的时候，
我是很想接近你的，
但是因为一一段时间就会爆发一次我刚才说的那种类似的争吵，
他就说就会有点生理的抵抗，
就会感觉你怎么那么像呢？
呃，
我们俩现在情况是属于分房，
因为自从有了孩子之后，
我是全职待了3年，
他上班的时候，
当时是在事业单位上班，
他晚上也他还是想影响他的睡眠，
所以他就搬到客卧去了，
因为长期已经这样了嘛，
后来我们也都习惯了，
如果这个床上变成3个人，
大家都会觉得很挤，
偶尔孩子不在家的时候，
我们才能在一挤，
我是一直感觉是不是因为我们分房才会导致我们感情变差，
但他。
他认为是因为我们吵架，
所以感情才会变差，
另外最后一次的时候是他想靠近，
但是我当时是因为赌气很排斥。
呃，
其实后来也后悔了，
但是我现在有的时候会想，
我主动一点的话是不是也未尝不可，
我就当我点了个模子歌嘛，
放下一点面子想的认知里边，
我会认为男这件事情是要男生主动，
所以偶尔会闪过念头说，
呃，
是不是我主动也没有关系，
毕竟我是喜欢他的，
我只是抹不开面子。
答，
你提供一下应该怎么改变一下这种现状，
当然没关系了，
两口子之间，
别说两口子之间，
就是两个人谈恋爱这个过程当中，
女生主动也没有任何的关系，
有些时候男生是非常享受被女生壁咚的感觉的，
这没有任何问题。
其实我静下心来的时候，
我会能知道他大概会喜欢什么样类型的女生，
然后在我不吵架的时候，
我其实也是很想和他去接触的，
所以这也是为什么我会想要好好进入这个婚姻，
好好的用这个心法。
从今天开始，
每次你想反驳他的时候，
就在心里默念这4个问题，
就嗯，
好，
老公你说了算，
老公，
我听你的，
我觉得你说的有道理。
老公，
你试一下，
他心情好了，
他没准他太主动了啊，
他会非常喜欢这种，
因为他还挺喜欢别。
人崇拜的那种感觉。
第三个问题就是他的性格，
其实是比较会聊天的那种，
但是并不是说是是那种，
怎么说呢，
甜言蜜语，
或者是那种有点该溜子的人，
他并不是那种，
他其实挺爱读书，
所以跟别人聊天的时候是那种侃侃而谈的。
正常跟男生聊天我肯能不会不开心，
但是跟女生聊天的时候我会不开心，
很能时候自己会生闷气，
我会没有安全感。
之前跟他讲过这个问题的时候，
当时是因为我说啊，
那你能不能给我保证你不会喜欢别人，
如果你喜欢别人就会告诉我，
想让我蒙在鼓里。
他就说其实是因为我们俩吵架，
我们俩之间感情不够好，
所以我才心里没有底气，
就是只要我们俩不吵架了，
他说那我们俩多好呀。
所以我想问一下，
他这样说是对的嘛，
我该怎么调整心态？
哎呀，
我之前好，
我是感觉他会不会PV我姑娘，
其实真的没有对错，
一个猴一个双板，
你现在需要明确的是什么，
我想要的是什么，
如果我想要的是跟这个男的好好过，
那我就一切其他所有我的人事物，
揭示我的工具，
揭示我的手段，
我就要动用这些，
甚至包括我的情绪，
甚至包括我的吃醋，
甚至包括我的眼泪，
全是我的工具，
全。
我的手段，
我的目的只会围绕说我想得到什么结果，
如果我想跟这个男的过的话，
我就真的是对症下药，
一个猴儿一个栓法，
他如果说想要的是崇拜的话，
我就给他这种崇拜感，
他如果想要的是我吃醋的话，
我就给他这种吃醋的感觉，
他如果想要的是大方的话，
我就给他这种大方的感觉。
总之也好，
一个穿法没有对错，
你要去研究你的关系，
研究这个男人，
我其实是知道他喜欢什么样子的，
其实我也会愿意去这么做，
我会有点放不下自己的面子，
这个面子也是我的工具，
我以前我跟姐妹们说过，
我要到我们家财政大全的时候，
我还哭了呢，
我哭的时候我还开着门哭呢，
我还假装很委屈呢，
都是我的工具，
都是我的手段，
我特别清楚的知道我想要的东西是什么，
我想要的结局是什么。
再有一个问题就是我俩谈恋爱的时候，
他还会去发朋友圈呀，
后来因为我们俩在结婚之前吵过一次很大的架，
当时我们互相都赌气把朋友圈删了，
从那之后他就没有再发过我们俩朋友圈，
哪怕后来结了婚生了娃。
我之前因为这件事情我还跟他掰扯过，
他给我的回答是，
他觉得他现在还没有非常好的事业，
他的身边的朋友都没有结婚生子，
他觉得他自己这个老婆孩子这炕头了，
他想稳定一下有没有他认为非常好的事业。
的时候，
我就会感觉他有想给自己留后路，
但是吧，
他日常的时候，
比如说他会把他工资的2/3都交给我，
而他主动要交给我，
每个月按时交，
或者说掌柜的收钱，
包括我们家就是他家嘛，
是属于拆迁的，
每个月会有一些拆迁补助，
他的妈妈也都是每个月直接打到我的账户里，
他这些都是知道的，
比如说过年过节，
我的生日什么的，
他妈妈也都是会给我发一些大额的红包。
因为我比较纠结，
一方面就感觉有些事情我不开心，
另外一方面他又做了一些实实在在的事情，
我该怎么去判断，
做万全的准备？
什么叫做万全的准备呢？
就这个猴在我身边，
我能过挺好，
这猴儿有一天死了，
这猴儿有一天上天桥上啥把势去了，
它不回来了，
我照样能过好，
你必须要有做这样的万全的准备哈，
你不能说指着这一只猴，
它死了我也得死，
他跑了我没饭吃，
那不行的，
好的，
你最后一个问题就是我目前是有工作的，
我们俩的工资其实是差不多的的，
工作是比较相对来说稳定一为双休工作，
作息也比较正常，
他可能会分那种早中晚班，
每个月可能他是单休，
我是感觉我现在的工作比较稳定一点，
虽然挣的不是很多吧，
有的时候跟他吵架的时候会在想。
我要要换一份挣得多一点的工作，
比较忙一些，
力更生一些，
可以姐妹啊，
换一个挣得多比较忙的工作，
对于你来说是有好处的。
我跟你讲，
所有的人都是幕墙的，
所有的无论男女都是幕墙的，
这个我是从哪个故事里面提取出来的感受呢？
潜伏这个电视剧里面的翠屏，
刚开始出现在于泽成的世界里面的时候，
于泽成都嫌他脏，
他给于泽成撕几个泡馍的话，
于泽成都吃不下去，
就嫌他又脏又土又没文化，
又抽烟又臭又这那的，
都嫌弃他。
相处了一段时间了之后，
于泽成都想把他送走，
想尽一切办法想把他送走，
但他为什么后来于泽成跟翠萍好上了，
喜欢上翠萍了，
是因为余则成见识了在翠萍他自己的领域里面，
翠萍的那个枪法很稳，
就是10环，
10环，
10环一枪就把陆乔山干下了。
同那之后，
你有没有发现余则成看翠萍的眼神从此都是骚哄哄的，
为什么呢？
因为他看到了这个女人在自己的那业领域里面是顶尖的，
是拔尖的。
那一瞬间，
他才真正看见了翠萍，
真正喜欢上他，
依恋上他。
你说一猴一个身法，
你怎么能保持这只猴儿围在你身边，
要让他看到你在你的专业领域，
在你的工作上，
在你的人情往来上，
在你的事业上，
你就做到了金牛就去挣钱多的地方去。
我想过，
但现在有几个小的卡点是，
一个是孩子现在是在上幼儿园，
学校已经开始做幼小衔接了，
我会考虑说如果我找一个比较忙的工作的话，
可能对孩子上的照顾就会变少一些。
另外一个就是是我老公是不太想让我接一些出差的工作的，
可能会不放心，
他之前也频繁的说过，
他再多挣一些钱的时候不希望我工作，
我内心是我不不会答应这件事情呢，
但是我当时也都是像你说的糊弄过去了，
你说好呀，
等到时候再说吧。
所以根据这3个卡点的话，
你会怎么建议呢？
你想要什么？
你想不想自己成为被别人牵挂，
生怕你跟有钱的男的跑了，
你想不想成为这样的人，
你想你就去做好，
就这样啊，
好，
谢谢，
拜拜。
人和人的关系，
他非常的奇妙，
以我的这种感受来说的话，
与其我天天担心我这只猴跑了，
不如让他担心我的跑了。
人和人的关系就是在动态平衡的，
我的态度就是，
与其我天天担心他跟别的女的跑了，
不如让他担心我跟别的男的跑了啊，
总有一个人要担心的两口子，
与其让我自己成为那个我天天患得患失的，
今天怎么那么晚回来啊？
今天他没有接我的视频电话，
今天他没有及时回我的消息，
与其让我自己扮演这个角色，
不如让他担心我记得点赞关注哦。